[Music]
come and sleep with me when if those was
loose that innocence it might
be if I be me
we can't get ahead they said I am so to
losing all that might be
wrong if might be
me you're sting red I'm at Hot Shot back
prend the shot hasn't hit you yet like a
switch I'm so on and off again it's hard
to believe
myself and I
regret I am not who I want to be it
hurts so badly yeah it's what you did
but the armet hopefully live so
happily sometimes I want to
foret where I am I give in I'm being sad
sometimes I want to see ride for no
reason and I just see the riding on the
[Music]
wall you where I am I give in and
thinkig
sometimes I want to
see
like and I just see the riding on the
wall sometimes I want to
foret where I am I give in I'm being sad
sometimes I want to see red for no
reason and I just see the riding on the
wall sometimes I want
to where I am I get and I can see the
riding down the wall I want to see right
for no
reason and I just see the riding on the
wall sometimes I want to
[Music]
break I get I'm being sad sometimes I
want to see
right and I just see the riding on the
wall
and I just see the riding on the
[Music]
wall and I just see the Ring of
wall I can't where I am I give it the
[Music]
[Applause]
big
hey there friends so this was a fun
project I am currently cooling my jets
in upper Michigan after having gone and
taught at Great Lakes flow Retreat uh in
the lower Peninsula I'm currently in the
upper peninsula and and I thought I
would take you all around to several
locations that have meaning uh for my
family we settled here in this country a
little over 100 years ago and there are
some spots like this here Farmhouse here
that uh have been a part of our family
ever since this is The Farmhouse that my
grandfather and my mother both grew up
in um and it's a place that I used to
come at when I was a we little TI to
spend my Summers uh so uh if you would
like to grab a set of those uh sock poy
that I was using in this video you can
do that by heading on over to Socko do
store and using my special chomo code
Drex factor that gets you a discount on
your order and it helps out the channel
so everybody wins also those sock po are
made by the wonderful kti staka NOA so
please support her she's an amazing flow
artist um big thanks you to go out to
the Friends of the channel big thanks go
out to dark monk fire Mecca uh flow
fests flow toys juggling calling pyroar
light toys spinballs and Ultra poy for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible uh you can learn more
about all these amazing companies uh by
checking out the links that I have down
in the description of this video and
special thank you to the non- business
friend of the channel That is fellow
Finn Becca Becken thank you so very much
for supporting my channel my work and my
mission GTO Pon
um also this video would not be possible
oh my God this sweat is getting up in my
eyes here this video would not be
possible without the kind support of all
of these nice people right here these
are my flow patrons over on patreon they
and the people listed down in the
description help to make this video and
all the videos on this channel possible
thank you one and all for your very
generous support and if you out there
watching are not currently a supporter
but you'd like to become one you can do
that by heading on over to
patreon.com drexfactor PO and signing up
uh there you can get access to a whole
host of awesome Rewards but even better
than that you'll be helping me out in my
mission to bring po spinning and flow
Arts to the whole wide world so go check
that out please and thank you finally if
you'd like to check out more of my flow
videos I'm going to include a uh link to
a playlist of videos I've done before
this one down in the description as well
as up on screen if you're watching on
YouTube also the YouTube algorithm
thinks that you might like this top
video here uh because it's also been
popular amongst other viewers of my
channel so maybe give that a look as
well thanks so much for watching make
sure to get out and flow today and I'll
see you with a new video real soon
peace